HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: We have a long story short
Please give a brief introduction
Tell everyone about your work, your business
And your company's strategy to enter the global market
Let's start with Mor.
Ok
MOR SHANI: My name is Mor from Jelly Button Games.
I am one of the company's co-founders and CEO.
Our main business is to develop free casual games.
Our first successful work was Pirate King.
50 million downloads so far
We are still working hard to enter the global market
What else do you want me to talk about?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Can you talk about entering the global market?
After all, this is your company's goal.
Or will we talk about this topic later?
MOR SHANI: Yes.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Ok
Then let's talk about this later.
Next, please introduce Massimo.
MASSIMO CIOCIOLA: Hello everyone, my name is Massimo.
Everyone calls me Max
This is simpler
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Oh, really?
MASSIMO CIOCIOLA: Yes
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: I didn't know it before.
MASSIMO CIOCIOLA: It's much simpler.
I am one of the co-founders and CEOs of Musixmatch.
Musixmatch is the world's largest lyrics database
It’s a pity that I am not a singer.
Currently, we have downloaded more than 50 million times worldwide.
Thank you very much for the invitation from the organizers.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Thank you!
Then let Andres introduce
ANDRES BOU: My name is Andres.
Is the CEO and co-founder of Social Point
We are a game company based in Barcelona
Our best known game is Dragon City.
And Monster Legends
According to statistics, the download volume of Dragon City
Has exceeded 150 million times
We have also entered the global market to a large extent.
GILBERT WERDAM: Is there a sound in my microphone?
FEMALE SPEAKER: No
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Is there such a thing?
GILBERT WERDAM: Okay.
one two Three
One or two
Hi
Hello everyone
My name is Gil.
Is the design director of Citymapper
Citymapper is a city-built city.
Traffic application
We collect all kinds of ready-made messy data
Try to figure out the clue
Then develop and design a product based on this
Mainly to guide users from one place to another
The app is currently available in 30 cities in 10 countries.
REGINA CHAMMA: Hello, my name is Regina.
I am the head of business development for Google Play in Latin America.
Mainly responsible for business in Brazil and Mexico
I am very happy to meet you here.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Ok
Let's start talking about it.
For the next discussion
More interactive
I will ask questions, please answer them one by one.
After that, more interaction
Then ask the audience if there is any problem.
If so, please join our discussion
First of all, I want to ask you all.
What is your company's strategy to enter the global market?
What are the challenges your company faces in the global market?
If you enter the global market, what challenges does your company face?
What challenges have you faced?
Ok, Gil talks about it first.
GILBERT WERDAM: You can basically imagine
Globalization is what we have to do
Key work
Our strategy is always
Localize products as much as possible
Therefore, every time we launch an app in a city, we will design all the traffic icons by hand.
We will go to these cities in person.
Specialized responsible personnel are also arranged for each city.
In terms of culture
Our app has always maintained a humorous style
In addition, really understand the accent of the locals
Very important for localized train information
By hiring local language and local people
We have solved this problem to some extent.
It’s a bit like doing it inside the company.
Always reach the most natural level
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Mother tongue check?
Does your company conduct a mother tongue check?
GILBERT WERDAM: Yes.
that's it
Ok
Everyone continues
MASSIMO CIOCIOLA: For us, globalization is everything
Because when we talk about music and lyrics
Talking about a huge object, which can be seen from some data.
According to statistics, the number of unique music tracks in the world
The only thing is that each track is only counted once.
About 4 million
60% of them are mainly English songs
Followed by Spanish, Chinese, Japanese
Tracks in many other languages, such as Hindi, Portuguese, Italian, and French.
In fact, these languages ​​do cover these languages.
We have to cover so many languages
Therefore, localization is a strategy that must be implemented for us.
I mean, in terms of content
We cover more than 80 different languages
So the challenge we face is
Music is basically a crowdsourcing platform
The greater our development in a certain country
The more... you mentioned Japan before
Japan is very important to us
Because the scale of our development in Japan is bigger
The more content added by Japanese users
We gave the user the right to localize the content.
I want to share with you if you launch new content in your app.
Whether it's lyrics or other content, no matter what
You must localize
Must provide localized content
However, as you said before, this does not mean just translating the content of the app.
But must provide content that meets local needs
Very representative of Brazilians who don’t like certain types of music
Different from the Germans' preferences
American music preferences are different from Japanese
Therefore, we must provide content that meets local needs.
Also protect the copyright owner’s local rights
Because no matter where in the world, we pay the copyright owner the appropriate fee.
But I have to say that this is for us
Is a very critical strategy to meet the challenge
If we can’t do it, we can’t really do business in any country.
Just like we are in Japan, but we don’t provide Japanese lyrics.
This is a bit...
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Did you say that your company first published the app?
But not localized to Japanese?
MASSIMO CIOCIOLA: I want to say that under normal circumstances, we will not
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: I mean to launch the app first.
Then there are product details
MASSIMO CIOCIOLA: I mean, we won’t immediately
Localize the app
Say back to how to localize the app
Our goal is to let users translate
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: What is the translation?
MASSIMO CIOCIOLA: Yes, translated content
And the application itself
I mean, when users complain, they will say, can someone help?
This is also extremely important
In addition to letting users use the translation tools provided by Google
We also allow users to update local content
I think the power to give users something to do
And getting advice from them is very important
Then we analyze the relevant data and listen carefully and consider the user’s suggestions.
I think everyone mentioned here.
There are many things you can do with Google Analytics.
I think this is an important resource for us.
With it, you can analyze the steady flow of data about any country.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Ok
Next, I want to ask the representatives of the game industry to talk about it.
MOR SHANI: Then let me point
Something different from them
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: I want to ask a few questions about the game.
MOR SHANI: Ok.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: I have talked about cultural adaptation.
Or entering a new market is an act of adapting to culture.
Or simply called localization
I want to ask Mor.
How do you see this problem?
The goal is to locate the original APK and localize a version
Still targeting the market [inaudible] APK?
MOR SHANI: First
I think everyone wants to enter the global market.
We are constantly working hard and investing a lot of energy and resources.
Of course, we must also consider the market potential and cost.
After all, the installation cost is too high.
Therefore, as a developer who is still in the early stage of the business, we must be very focused, and good steel is used in the blade.
We must pay great attention to this
So, when Pirate King was just started
We must look at the problem from a strategic perspective.
Consider how to reduce the barriers to localization
Because we are a newly developed game development company.
Can't afford a lot of money
Of course, there is not much money for marketing.
Not much money to enter the global market
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: So saving budget is the primary goal
MOR SHANI: Developers who have just started a business must consider these issues
We firmly believe that we must do our utmost to focus on developing excellent products.
Create beautiful products for users
Ensure a smooth experience
So I recommend everyone to listen.
A wonderful lecture by George Fan
He is the producer of Plants vs. Zombies.
Although the speech time is really good in 2010, I believe everyone will like it.
He talked about how to convince his mother to play Plants vs. Zombies.
PopCap gave us a lot of inspiration
Including many wonderful processes they designed
George Fan also gave a detailed introduction in the lecture.
First interaction and localization process
He shared a lot of tips and very exciting ideas.
Even talked about how to use pop-up ads with more than eight words.
We realize that as a developer still in its infancy
We must use these techniques as soon as possible
We were really inspired by this process
Therefore, we have embedded such a process in Pirate King.
Later, we worked with the Google Play team
Developed this strategy together
Of course, we have a marketing team now.
We gradually started to enter...actually
Our company is located in Tel Aviv, Israel
So we started with the Israeli market.
Then start in Singapore, Malaysia
Conducting business in Thailand and Southeast Asia
No localization or special treatment for culture
Someone told us that we can't go through localization or special treatment for culture.
Direct access to the Thai market
We replied that we believe that products are everything
We firmly believe that we can bring a satisfactory experience to users.
Our highest record is
Downloads in Southeast Asia alone reached 450,000 times a day
70% of them are downloaded through Google
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Have you localized your landing information?
MOR SHANI: No content is localized
We are only localized...
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Is the release information all in English?
MOR SHANI: Yes.
We localized a small portion of the store.
We take full advantage of the content community strategy
Of course, we also work closely with the Play team.
Pay close attention to the implementation of the strategy and then combine the two
The effect obtained is very significant
As a start-up developer
Must be based on specific markets and the energy and resources that can be invested
Focus on what you can do, then combine these factors
Develop a sound and effective strategy
Currently, we are entering the global market.
We now have the ability to enter the global market
But also pay attention to emerging markets
Our goal today is Latin America and the United States.
Of course, Europe
For us, the road ahead is long and we must continue to work hard.
ANDRES BOU: We have been distributing games all over the world.
We will look at the situation in various countries around the world.
Then will always release the game based on a KPI
Because it is easier to manage
When we started to focus specifically on certain markets
We will consider it comprehensively
The effect of all KPIs
Such as [inaudible], profitability, etc.
In addition to the core content of the game
We changed a lot of other content
We changed the cover of the Play Store, the name of the game.
We conduct special marketing campaigns for each market.
Marketing activities in different markets are very different
Naturally, we will work with local partners to translate
We will also change the icon
We will set different pricing for certain markets.
In addition, we also provide some [inaudible] or offers
And the solutions for different markets are different.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Your company is outside Barcelona
Are there other offices?
ANDRES BOU: What?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Your company is outside Barcelona
Are there other offices?
ANDRES BOU: We opened an office in Tokyo
In fact, no one is working in Tokyo.
But we did set up Social Point Tokyo there.
We very much hope to expand the scale
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Ok
We only have five minutes.
Do you have any questions?
GILBERT WERDAM: Do you still have to ask between you?
If not, let us ask the audience.
Do you have any problems with each other?
There's none?
No
Ok
Let's ask the audience.
Do you have any questions to ask the discussion group?
Everyone can ask questions at will.
Ok
Audience: I have a question I want to ask
Constantly changing icons around the world to adapt to the local market
Have you ever worried?
The company's brand consistency problem?
Have you ever encountered such a problem?
MOR SHANI: Do you mean to change the brand?
Audience: Yes, if you change the icon
And the icon has nothing to do with your brand.
Obviously this will change the user’s impression of the brand.
GILBERT WERDAM: It is for this reason
We have not changed the icon
Because it is part of the brand itself
Instead, I did a lot of A/B tests on the screenshots.
Yes, we have done a lot of A/B tests on this.
As for the icon, at least our situation is not changing the icon
But maybe the game is a bit different.
However, as a practical application
I think icons are an integral part of the brand.
But I really hope to experience this practice.
Because I will be curious if we change the icon
Will it produce significant results?
MASSIMO CIOCIOLA: One thing happened to us here.
Really scared me
We used a screenshot in the app.
Make the user think of the cover of the album
Once, some of our screenshots were taken from Katy Perry's picture.
Of course, we paid royalties for all images.
In the picture she wears a bikini
It seems that there is nothing wrong with it.
As a result, we received a large number of complaints from Arab users.
We didn’t even think that this would happen.
Who can expect such a thing?
Who can expect this to offend others?
So, we started the A/B test from that time.
We no longer use those screenshots
After that we found that the situation improved a lot.
I think this situation is like
You went to a country that you don’t know
There may be some things that are culturally different.
Specific differences vary by country
So you have to know more about it.
You should ask your own users
I mean, we are developing too fast and some aspects are not well considered, so I am used to asking users for their opinions.
Get their feedback
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: You said A/B test
MASSIMO CIOCIOLA: A/B testing is very practical
I think that on this matter
We should all thank Google
As far as beta testing is concerned
We can all say that we got 15,000 employees for free.
As soon as we release the app, the user will test it immediately.
And provide us with feedback
Really great
Unfortunately, not all applications are using this method.
ANDRES BOU: For us, we are just a bit tangled
For example, in most promotional activities
We changed the icon for each country
In Japan, we use a specific icon
In Europe and the US, we use other icons.
In addition, we also change the icon for the same region.
For example, we are currently launching a new version of the game.
Both versions are linked
We replaced the previously used icon with a new icon
But after we made these changes
We are worried about whether the brand will be affected
The audience’s question is very good.
So we try to keep the essence of the icon
Keep the style of the icon unchanged and add a look
It’s like saying to the user: Hey, the game is launching new content!
Therefore, we take very careful consideration of brand issues when making changes on the icon.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Someone asked here
Audience: Ok, thank you.
My name is Alexis and I am from eRepublik Apps.
I want to ask Andres a few questions about prices that vary from place to place.
How important is the price to suit the local situation?
For example, I am thinking
In a country like Latin America
Certain types of games may be more profitable
Does the price really have a big impact on the local situation?
In addition to income, will it also affect the retention rate?
In addition, take your multiplayer game
Whether the player will be in communication
Complaining about the price?
They may say that I play so much in the US and you spend so much, our expenses are different.
What is the risk of this situation?
ANDRES BOU: We have not encountered this situation yet.
You mean that the complaints from users in two different regions are right?
For example, Latin American users have reached 20% of our DAU
And income only accounts for 4% of our total revenue.
If analyzing payment status
You’ll find payment methods for Latin American users.
With European users
Or a US user’s payment method is completely different
So we adjusted the corresponding pricing
We have found income in some regions and markets
From 10% to 25%
What I want to say is that it is very important to understand the price.
I will not wait and see from the beginning.
I will launch the game and see what DARPU is.
That is, the average daily revenue per user
Then make corresponding improvements and try to increase revenue.
10%, 15%, 20% [inaudible]
REGINA CHAMMA: I want to add a little
I think we are actually in some areas
Price experiment
For emerging markets, this is definitely a new concept.
I am not talking about Brazil and Latin America alone.
But all emerging markets
In fact, Google has invested heavily in these markets.
We are not just introducing technology to these regions.
Still investing in human resources
We are expanding the consumer market
In fact, we are trying to guide users to buy digital goods.
We have not provided such guidance in Japan because people there are already used to buying digital goods.
We have not done this in the United States or the United Kingdom.
Users in these emerging markets are learning
How to use your smartphone to interact with digital goods, games, or apps
So actually we need to guide them
For example, we just launched a local payment method in Brazil and Mexico.
Until last year, the Play Store only accepted
International credit card payment
So this is a big effort we made
Not just for Latin America
But for all emerging markets
And we intend to promote it and guide users how to use it.
But I firmly believe that the price is adjusted specifically for certain markets.
Is a very important measure
This is very difficult for everyone because there are too many markets, right?
Therefore, I suggest that you prioritize
For example, is there a 20% install?
Are they from a certain market?
Is there a market that needs to be studied in depth?
If the answer is yes, then the strategy you should take is
Try to understand the price that is really suitable for this market
And user behavior in the market
However, this is us
In the next few months or even years
The direction of hard work
If you think of most emerging markets
For example, 80% need to adjust the price, then this is a big problem.
We are continually working on it
Make sure users know they can spend on the Play Store
I think this is what we have done.
ANDRES BOU: In addition to pricing, there are
Do we have extra time? no yet?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: We need to end the discussion.
If you still need to express your opinion, you can...
ANDRES BOU: I know Alexis, I can talk to him later.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Ask him later.
Thank you for participating in our seminar.
This concludes the discussion on entering the global market.
If you have any questions, please feel free to contact us.
And ask us questions
thank you all!
Please applaud our discussion team, thank you!
[applause]
[play music]